les fuites il est menteur 12 celle au jt
après jt de patrick chan fouet sais pas
[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais soir
cyril ça fait quelque chose
ah mais moi je me suis fait trembler
l'intérieur j'ai un micro quand on était
petits et grands noms des jeunes est
ressorti à bravo bonsoir bonsoir c'est
patrick geoffrey va nous amener un tic
au sérieux dans cette émission
effectivement cyril de type politique
finies les vacances retour du cap d'agde
pour l'ancien ministre
attendez vous allez devoir le faire
parce que votre micro était branché de
graviers alors on démarre avec la
politique
politique l'ancien ministre dominique
strauss kahn appelle bien évidemment
ainsi vous êtes exposés au soleil
il est important de se joindre à
bondoukou moindre je fais ça c'est un
mot sur granit eu aussi alors que sur
dissoudre rien le corps avec niveau de
crème solaire vraiment toutes les
parties pas les couilles économies
économies l'état vient de rembourser
l'ancien président du front national
jean marie le pen à hauteur de 4,2
millions d'euros et apparemment il y
aurait tout claquer chez art
je pensais pas un jour voient comme un
monsieur jean marie le pen est en jeu
mais on a même t-shirt bas je voulais
vous en prendre internationale
international la chancelière angela
merkel visiblement très heureuse de
rouvrir les écoles en allemagne une
femme qui a des convictions et court
toujours après de longs mois de
confinement depuis de longs mois de
vacances scolaires c'est enfin le retour
en classe dont les élèves de cm2 donc je
vais mettre des choses je vais vous en
prendre on parlait de la ministre de la
culture hier victime en bachelor est
justement culture et bien écoutez je
rebondis là dessus malheureusement la
rentrée ne se fait pas pour tout le
monde puisque les artistes attendent
toujours la réouverture des salles de
spectacles visiblement ça commence à
faire long pour teva dams
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sa vie nous sommes armés lavier
visiblement ça commence à être long pour
kavanagh brat ok vous des jeunes
évidemment j'ai bien c'est le gars c'est
sa bière on termine avec de la
télévision exactement voté ni télécom de
télévision télé j'aime bien ce télé il
ya comme une diff tongs total
je vais pas m'amuser à son départ de
france a les médias
patrick sébastien a tourné dans un
épisode de camping paradis sera diffusé
sur tf1 en exclusivité les premières
images du tournage on n'a jamais
retrouvé la scène par d'autres respecte
les artisanes évidemment non mais c'est
vrai que tous les libéraux cycliste pas
sur toi derniers mois nos d un oui voilà
c'était le jt après le jt
c'était patrick chan frais et c'était
vraiment sympa d'être avec vous
[Applaudissements]